and the intention for today's hour is
really just to relax
um just to unwind not a lot of
information coming at you
just embodied practices and i know that
a lot of you probably have
commitments at home right now maybe kids
coming in and so really just
do what you can and take those breaks as
needed and
and really there's no pressure to do
this in any certain way
so we're just going to start with
something that helps us relax
and that's stretching and a little bit
of massage
it might be nighttime or evening where
you are so it might be cooler
so just take a moment to notice
the temperature and the environment
around you
and then just take a moment to notice
the feeling of your body
on the chair or the surface that you're
on
and notice where your hands are resting
maybe notice if you're leaning forward
or leaning back or
if there's any adjustment that you'd
like to make so there's more ease in
your body
and we're just going to set the
intention of letting go
of time
so that sounds like a giant task but
we'll see if we can
touch into this sense of timelessness as
if we had all the time in the world
to let go and unwind
and just take a moment to connect with
your breath
breathing in through your nose
and then breathing out a little slower
through your nose or mouth
just letting our nervous system start to
unwind
and then just let your breath find its
own natural easy rhythm
letting go of any effort
and then just notice any sensations in
your body
so you might be hungry
you might be full
you might notice your eyes are
fluttering
and just as we notice these sensations
we don't have to try and change them or
make them
different but we can just kind of greet
them with curiosity
and acceptance this is how things are
right now that's okay
if you happen to notice pain it might be
difficult to stay with that sensation
so you can just touch into any sensation
of pain
and then find a place in your body where
there's ease
and sometimes we really have to search
for ease maybe it's at the tip of our
big toe or one of our thumbs
but somewhere in the body usually
there's
a contact with ease
so just allowing us to be as we are in
this moment
less than perfect just as we are
and we're just going to add in a little
bit of movement here
just to stretch our body gently and if
any of these movements
don't work for you you can just stay
resting whatever position is comfortable
so if you'd like to open your eyes to
see these stretches
you can or you can keep your eyes closed
and just follow my
verbal instructions so go ahead and
anchor your hand to a spot next to you
maybe you're holding onto a chair
or your fingertips are resting on a
couch or
a desk and then we're going to lift our
left arm up lift our left fingertips
toward the sky
and just feel that length all the way
down from your fingertips to your hip
and then we're just going to slowly
reach over to our right
you can look down if that is nice on
your neck or you can look
up and i'm just keeping my eyes closed
just to stay embodied
just to stay with the pleasant
sensations
of stretch and loosening up the muscles
and take a deep breath here feeling your
lungs expand
and a deep breath out
and then reaching back up to the center
and then just letting that left arm
float down
and just pause to notice the different
sensations between the side we stretched
and the one
we haven't stretched yet
subtle tingling or heat
maybe more space in your diaphragm to
breathe
and then we'll go to the other side so
just lifting that right arm
up toward the sky reaching the
fingertips up
anchoring your left hand and then reach
up and over toward your left
feeling that stretch from your right hip
all the way through
to your right fingertips and again you
can look down
you can look up
and just take a few deep breaths feeling
your lungs expand
and then on your next in-breath just
reaching back up
and as you exhale slowly
letting that right arm drift down
and again just pausing here
noticing if you feel a little different
than when we started
maybe you can feel the nervous system
start to
unwind
and if not that's okay too sometimes our
nervous system kind of holds on tight to
what's going on or what kind of day we
had
right so that's okay too
and then you can open your eyes and just
follow along we're just going to do a
few
movements to give ourselves some love
give our muscles some love so just go
ahead if it's comfortable for you and
you don't have any injuries just go
ahead and squeeze
gentle squeeze here right where your
your shoulder blades
this is where we hold a lot of tension
and then down the arm
all the way down to your forearm and
give a little squeeze to your hand and
your fingers
and let's just do that one more time
going back up
squeezing
and then again pause just to notice the
difference between the side we squeezed
and the side we haven't yet
and it's all about awareness right we're
just bringing awareness to ease
so we can identify it right and then
let's go to the other side so just
giving a nice squeeze to that shoulder
blade
anywhere you feel tight you can stay in
that area if you'd like
and then you can just work your way down
the arm giving a squeeze to the shoulder
and the forearm all the way down to your
hand
maybe just look down at your hand in
your fingers thinking about all the
things that they do
right they type and they hug
cook dinner wash dishes just giving love
and then again just pausing
and seeing if you can really feel into
the sensations
maybe tingling maybe lightness
maybe some ease emerged
and we're going to do one last movement
so we're going to make fists with our
hands like this
you can tuck the thumbs under your
fingers
and just hold the squeeze for a few
moments
noticing what happens in the mind as we
tense up
this is kind of representative of how we
sometimes hold on to things or resist
what's happening and then take a deep
breath into your nose
and as you breathe out just release the
hands
opening the palms
this hand gesture kind of represents
letting go
or accepting or being open and curious
notice how different that is
and then the last movement we'll do if
you want to open your eyes to
look is just imagine you're kind of
hugging a tree
right and relax the shoulders down we
don't want them to be up
toward your ears and imagine this
gesture this posture is like we're
holding whatever
we encounter in this next 40 minutes
together with kindness
whether someone interrupts our session
or
we don't feel it we don't feel what we
think we're supposed to be feeling
see if we can hold all of that with
kindness
and compassion
and then we can rest our hands back down
opening our eyes
so hopefully the nervous system has
started to
enter what we call the rest and digest
mode of operating right our
parasympathetic nervous system
the next few activities we're going to
do are all about that
all about activating our parasympathetic
nervous system which is the opposite
of our sympathetic nervous system uh
which is our what we call fight or
flight
right when we're stressed or we're
trying to get things done or we're
rushed
right we want to move into the other way
the opposite of that
so i have a little exercise
which is about thinking about teachers
that you've had in your life and these
don't have to be teachers you've had at
school but any kind of teacher that's
left
an impression on you someone that has
taught you something
or connected with you someone with whom
you felt really
seen and i want you just to reflect on
that
and maybe a few people could share
what comes up when you think about that
and as you're thinking as you're
processing i'll just share
who a person i thought of she was my
11th grade science teacher
and i was really disenchanted with
school
at the time i felt like i wasn't able to
really focus on what i wanted to focus
on which was neuroscience and psychology
and she happened to go to ucla which at
the time was my dream school
and she gave me a textbook from one of
her neuroscience classes that she still
had
and she told me that at any time i could
go sit in at classes
sit in on classes at ucla and it just
i was so appreciative of that because
first of all she
she took my interest seriously she gave
me a book that was
special to her and she let me know that
i could pursue my interests
and i didn't have to wait for it i could
go sit in on a lecture and be part of it
even though i wasn't i
hadn't graduated high school yet so that
was a teacher that really
um left that i'll never forget i'll
remember her for the rest of my life
so is there anyone who'd like to share
just a story
of a teacher you can share verbally i
would love to hear your voices
and i totally understand too if you
you're not able to share
uh verbally because of what's going on
at home but yeah
who's a teacher in your life that you've
had maybe it's even a teacher who
inspired you to go into this profession
and um yeah we're getting a number of
great um responses in the question
section which is awesome
um carrie says um her 9th to 12th grade
music teacher was totally present and
authentic
such an encouragement to all students
and katie says
fifth grade teacher that i worked with
when i was a para i still think about
him and my classroom plans
and then just to get a couple of folks
to share live i see some folks have
raised their hand so i'm going to
actually
unmute crystal davis here okay um so
crystal
if you like you are now live with sam
hi crystal
sometimes it can take a little while for
the audio to kick um
crystal feel free to share i'm also
going to go over to
teresa here
theresa if you're there feel free to
share okay
it said i was muted can you hear me now
yeah we can hear wait yeah
okay awesome so uh for me it's my fifth
grade teacher
her name was gail lydie i remember her
like it was yesterday
i had a very challenging childhood i'll
just leave it at that to make it
comfortable for everyone
but she showed me that she loved me even
though i felt so uncomfortable
and the biggest thing of all is that i
was actually able to meet her after i
finally got my degree
six years ago and i did my student
teaching
and she told me how proud of me that she
was
and so i got a chance to have that last
conversation with her
before she passed away so just very
super precious
that's my share that's amazing
thank you for sharing that and i heard
that the word love
really resonated with me like you you
know when you're loved you know when
you're
um when you're cherished by someone
even if it is a teacher you know that
kind of connection
can can translate or transcend to love
and it's uh that's why we're here i
always say that's why we're here on
earth
you know we're here to connect we're
here to love so
it's an amazing connection you had and
so great that you were able to
meet with her and let her know what
impact she had on you because when we're
kids and my husband just told me this
too he's like we never
get thank yous you know the only thank
yous that come are
when maybe when the students are older
and they realize
you know how important and how what
sacrifices teachers made and what effort
they brought forth to the classroom
so yeah i'm sure it meant a lot to her
thank you so much crystal for that
amazing share
let's go over to teresa teresa i'm going
to unmute your line
you're still there yes yes
so i had a college professor in algebra
that was a very difficult class it was
my third algebra class trying
to take just to get through so i could
even take a college algebra course
was feeling very overwhelmed and quite
frankly very
stupid when it came to algebra and
he told me that
even if you don't get it one way and
showed me that if you don't get it one
way there's always another way
to solve a problem which is something
that i've taken
not just when it comes to math but i've
taken it in life as well
that there's multiple ways to solve our
problems
um and don't just stick with that one
method
that's something that i brought into my
teaching as well because i do the same
thing with my students now
if they can't get it one way then let's
look at it a different way
and it's been very successful and has
been a good thing for me to learn
so i'm very thankful to mr cherry who's
an algebra teacher in college wow
that's a beautiful story and the fact
that he was able to connect it or you
were connecting it to life
just that there's always when we hit a
roadblock
we have this capacity to come up with
creative solutions or ways of looking at
problems differently
and not just by ourselves but even
asking for help and being able to
you know ask our teachers to help us
look at something a new way
that's beautiful thank you so much
thank you so
i would love for us to um i want to
you might not know this practice but
it's called loving kindness meditation
and it for for the skeptics out there it
can sound
kind of wooy because we're sending kind
wishes
to someone else and it's not that we're
in any kind of um delusional state that
we think
we can send wishes and they'll somehow
be received right
we're doing it for ourselves there's
been a lot of research on
this form of meditation and the
research has shown that it connects us
to um
well it has a lot of health benefits
right reduces inflammation
increases and boosts our immune system
but it also puts us
in touch with the the neural circuitry
that makes us want to connect
that helps us attune to each other and
helps us to
be present for another human being and
to be present
for ourselves um so it's really a
selfish exercise even though we're doing
something
um that sounds really benevolent for
others
but it also makes you want sometimes it
stimulates
this desire to reach out to the person
or to
write a letter of thank you or or to
really just
be with them in a in a deeper way so we
don't know exactly what it's going to do
but we go into it knowing
it will be in some way beneficial
so i would love for us to send some kind
wishes
to the teachers that you thought of that
the teacher that came to mind
and i'll lead you through it's a very
brief practice i'll lead you through it
and just keep this person in mind and
keep the feeling
um alive in you the feeling of
connection
of being seen of
that that that kind of freedom that you
had
when you from your algebra teacher when
you learned that you could look at
something a different way or that there
were multiple ways of solving it how
that kind of opened
it un like untied the knot
that you may have felt when you didn't
get something so just keeping that
feeling alive
and we can close our eyes if we're
comfortable
you can always rest your eyes on a spot
in front of you if you don't like to
close your eyes and let's just bring
that teacher to mind
you can imagine that they're in front of
you or next to you
maybe recall what they look like
their demeanor
and just recall the moment of connection
that you had with this teacher
and if no teacher came to mind you can
just think of someone you like or love
someone in your life
and if you'd like you can put a hand on
your heart
but you definitely don't have to
and i'm just going to say some words of
kindness out loud and just imagine that
you're sending this kindness
you're genuinely wishing for this person
to feel this way
may you be happy
may you know you're appreciated
may you be free from pain
may you be healthy
i'm just taking a breath to reconnect to
that feeling
of appreciation you have for this person
may you be happy
may you be safe
may you be healthy and at ease
and while we're here just bringing to
mind your own efforts
you can place your hand down if it's
getting tired
but bringing to mind your efforts
to show up when you don't feel like it
sometimes
your efforts to be on time to be present
you're genuine desire to show care
and concern for your students
for your family
all that effort and goodness
that you show to the world
and if exceptions come up if you start
thinking about well i'm not always like
that
right that's okay too just notice what
the mind does
what the mind shows you greet it with
remember that
holding with compassion and kindness
and we're just going to send some kind
wishes to ourselves
we're going to use the word you just so
we have that little bit of
space where our loving
kind self wishing it to our vulnerable
maybe sometimes hesitant self
so may you be happy
may you be safe
may you be free from pain
and may you have ease
taking a deep breath in and
out just to reconnect with your efforts
and your goodness
may you be happy
may you be safe
may you know you're appreciated
and may you feel at ease
i'm just staying with the feeling of
ease that maybe
has bubbled up from this exercise
or holding whatever's here skepticism
maybe a feeling of difficulty or
hesitation holding that with kindness
not resisting it
and when you feel ready you can open
your eyes
and i just want to open it up again to
the group
to see if anyone would like to share
what that was like for you
often when we do this loving-kindness
practice for the first time
it can be we have what we call the inner
heckler right we have this inner voice
kind of heckling us and saying what are
you doing what is this
um but maybe you've tried it before or
maybe it just felt really natural to you
so yeah just feel free to
jump in and share what that experience
was like for you
and again we can do it verbally or in
chat i love hearing your voices so
that's my preference but whatever you
can do
so christy says i'm always surprised
that this exercise can bring me to tears
yeah and abby said it made me want to
call my guiding teacher and say thanks
and then um i know there are a couple
folks who would want to share online so
i'm going to go ahead with carol first
so carol i've gone ahead and opened up
your line if you want to unmute yourself
feel free to say hi to sam hello can you
hear me
yeah hi carol hi i for me
um you know i i tell my students
to do these things and i don't always
tell myself to
and so to hear you as the teacher
telling me as the student to it
to send myself love you know it's that
kind of
switch that i think teachers need more
often
yeah so thank you you're welcome
it's so true right we get in the habit
of wanting to give advice
give give tools and then we're we forget
to do it for ourselves right
yeah and we need teachers right just
like we
we we never stop needing teachers and
helpers as we get older
and let's go next to elizabeth um
elizabeth feel free to
share your story with sam sure hi
um i always think it's awesome because i
have so many people i want to thank and
i'm grateful for and appreciate
but um i can't remember your name but
uh you said it brings you to tears and
that's what it always surprises me when
i do stuff like this you come in and
like it it happens you know when mine is
my brother
passed away at age 48 a couple years ago
and we had a teacher we both had in
sixth grade
and she ended up moving across the
street from my mom
and 15 years later
she had a picture that my brother had
given her like a school picture
he said you know and she told the story
she said
he asked well do you want a school
picture of me and she said well of
course i do
and so the next day he came in with an 8
by 10
and this is like in the mid early 80s
hey
so she kept it and had it when she moved
in across the street from my mom like 15
years later
and so it just was a pretty amazing
story that she was able to tell us
you know at my brother's funeral and
like she made a difference then
and continued to you know wow
wow what a special woman yeah
thank you for sharing that
and sam do you have time for one more
share yes we do
let's go over to um to jamie coates
actually
so jamie i'm gonna unmute your line feel
free to
open it up yourself
hi jamie
that looks like you might have a little
trouble with jamie oh okay
let me try with um jennifer here hold on
one second
jennifer are you there
oh yeah hi jennifer how are you i'm good
how are you
great thank you so much for joining yeah
i just i
again like everyone i'm echoing just the
sentiments of tears and
um i was surprised with how my other
senses really connected to
when i was thinking about my fourth
grade teacher going back to that
i could it was like it was in the
classroom and i could hear his laugh and
see his smile and
just felt so good um and and i made the
connection that
what made him so special he was always a
hundred percent present
with us as his students and that gift of
being present
um is not forgotten yeah
wow it's incredible
yeah the presence is is it's love
you know it's it's the ultimate show of
care
when you're present and it's hard it
gets harder to develop
in in these times so it's
you know when we we kind of need this
time to stop
and just reflect and i think we need
people to bring us into it
we need all the tools we can get to to
pull us in
to this time to connect with each other
to commune
to share stories so it's it's so
precious and when we do it i don't know
it sounds like
a lot of you are expressing this too but
when we do it we remember how good it is
how good it feels
and we want to do it again and again and
again so
yeah it's just rediscovering the
importance of community and connection
lovely so i want to take us into our
next
exercise which is all about ah
awe i feel like we don't use that word
very often because
these moments of awe um for most of us
happen infrequently right we a moment of
awe
to me and how it's been um defined by
the research is
these moments that leave you or
inspire this feeling of of surprise and
um you know you kind of feel small
because the thing
feels so big in a good way it feels
you feel expansive you feel inspired
you feel you're you're completely
absorbed
in that moment you're not thinking about
anything else because
the thing you're witnessing is so
beautiful or so touching or so
magnificent right so these are moments
of awe
and um reflecting there's a lot of
research and i can share with you
the research literature the the um
authors
there's a woman actually in canada who
does some these amazing workshops on awe
but um she's found in the research that
um
ah and is is really good for our mental
health it stimulates our vagal
vagus nerve which again activates our
parasympathetic nervous system and
and helps us to actually feel like we're
suspended in time right we lose track of
time
we're in this flow state so it's really
good for us
so i want to introduce you to this
activity so that you can put yourself in
that state of awe
and then hopefully find a lot of
extraordinary
moments in your or in the ordinariness
of of life of day-to-day life
so what i'm going to have you do is and
you can do this again with your eyes
open or closed i
like to shut my eyes just to close out
all the
visual stimuli but we're going to
think of a moment of awe that we've had
so think of a moment when you were
surprised and suspended for a moment
in this feeling of amazement
this feeling of connection maybe it was
a
connection with a person or a moment of
witnessing a child being born
or seeing a wedding
or someone some experience
where you felt really present
and in awe of the beauty
i'll give you a few moments in silence
just to
allow this memory to bubble up without
pushing it or rushing it
and as a moment comes to mind
see if you can expand it by noticing the
details
the sensory details so if there were
people involved
remembering what people were there
maybe even as you take a deep breath you
can remember the smell
the scents in the air
maybe you can remember the sounds
maybe you remember the temperature if it
was a hot day
or cold day neutral
and then remember what you saw
the colors the shapes the facial
expressions
the movements
then we're going to connect with a
movement
that represents this moment of awe
so maybe it's your arms open
or if you were holding something you
might
put your arms in that position so just
find a movement in your body right now
or a gesture that represents this moment
of
awe
and just hold that movement or posture
for a few breaths
helping you connect to that feeling
to let it soak in
maybe you notice the thoughts that you
had at the time or the emotions
and you can place your hands back down
and just let that feeling
simmer for just a few more moments
and then when you're ready you can if
your eyes are closed you can
open your eyes coming back to the space
that we have together
and i wanted to share um when i did this
exercise
for the first time what moment of all
came to mind and
i think jeremy has a photograph to pull
up
to show you um
it was when i was in i went when i was
15 i went to europe for the first time
and i saw the coliseum
oh that's a beautiful picture yeah
and i looked at it and i heard the tour
guides starting to
talk about the history and some
you know some major points they were
making stuck out like how old it was and
the events that used to take place
inside and
but what got me was the how old it was
just
how how it withstood all this time
passing and all these different events
in history and it just stood there
and it remained and my my gesture was
this
you can't see my hands in the shot but
like wow kind of
pushed back by it by how huge it was and
how
beautiful and i also just felt so lucky
to be there
i felt so lucky to witness this living
piece of history that i had learned
about in in a textbook and now i got to
see it
so that was my moment of awe and i
just i i really did lose track of time i
think i was there for hours but it felt
like only minutes went
by so i would love to
hear from you again just what was your
moment of awe
what came up for you what sensory
details
did you did you recall and what did it
feel like
to just stay in that feeling of awe
there's a lot of research showing that
it takes 30 seconds
to a minute for a positive emotion to
really register
in our system for us to kind of what
they say
or what they call hardwiring happiness
so that our default state becomes
more likely to look for the good to
look for what we're grateful for to
recall these moments of awe
it becomes more of a habit over time if
we really let it simmer and
and stay with us for longer periods of
time
so yeah so even talking about it and
listening to each other
is helping us to really develop that
hard wiring for
for the good looking for the good so we
can be fully present with each other as
we're listening
to these stories of awe and if you'd
like you can share your gesture and i
can
try to replicate it and we can all do it
together so that we're mirroring each
other and really maybe even
touching deeply into empathizing with
your experience
so who would like to share so we heard a
number of great ones in the question
section sam
yeah we used to talk about sunset on the
rim of the grand canyon
um jacqueline talked about the first
time i was out on the ocean without
being able to see the shore
jeanette said the moment of all that
really struck her when she was presented
with her daughter for the first time
and she looked into her daughter's eyes
and had a connection with her
that's lasted all the way into adulthood
wow
it's an incredible moment i i'm not a
parent yet but i imagine that moment of
i mean overwhelming awe when your child
is placed in your arms
and sometimes we'll do these exercises
with parents and kids and have them look
into each other's eyes and
talk about the color of their eyes like
i notice you're you have a little
ring around your eye and it's light
brown or whatever it is but for me
witnessing those moments of connection
and seeing parents
just their whole face light up as their
children are looking into their eyes is
for me that's a moment of awe
that i that i um happily get to
relive a lot of the time so yeah just
thank you for sharing that let's invite
some folks to join
live um let's start with michelle
so michelle i'm gonna unmute your line
feel free to do the same on your side
michelle are you there yes i am
hi michelle hi this
is amazing um the first time i held
each of my children and
it washed over me
the enormity of how my life would
change after that life as i had known it
would never be the same
and in ways i couldn't even at that time
imagine um
so that that
was awesome
it's beautiful i got chills all through
my head and back
as you were describing that that's
took my breath away yeah
yeah it's beautiful
was there a movement that came to mind
was it like holding or
yeah it was as
i cradled them in my arms and looked
down
at their little faces
and that was so many years ago they're
adults now
but i can
i can cherish that moment once again so
i appreciate this
i hadn't thought about that in many many
years
so thank you for that yeah
you're so welcome thank you for sharing
sometimes i look into
i work with children quite a bit and i
look into their eyes
as if i was their parent like i try to
connect with them with that kind of love
and unconditional positive regard
if you want to use therapy terms but
that feeling of connection
and we can kind of do that with other
people even strangers we can look at
them
through the eyes of a mother or sister
or friend
and and really connect to
each other on this level you know we
have that capacity it reminds me of
the algebra teacher you know kind of
asking us to look at
the problem of disconnection or
loneliness and maybe one solution is to
recall that feeling of love that we have
for people
in our lives and to maybe look at each
other through that
through that lens
yeah let's go over to lindsay
um lindsay i'm going to unmute your line
feel free to connect with sam
hi there can you guys hear me yeah hi
lindsay
um thank you so much sam um appreciate
this this is awesome
um so for me it was also when i was
traveling and i think there was a few of
us that said we were somewhere
far far away from home um so i was in
bagan myanmar a couple years ago
and i was watching the sunrise over
hundreds of thousands of
pagodas and it literally just seemed
like
time stopped um and the sun took forever
to come up
the the transformation of the sky and um
so that was really nice to kind of
go back and revisit that i haven't
looked at those photos in forever but i
was sitting on the pagoda
looking at the sunrise i was right there
back in that moment
and i'm i try not to focus too much on
the past try to focus on the
present and you know maybe the next day
or the next week but this was a nice
reminder that
it is okay to kind of go back to the
past and think of those
those moments of awe so thank you for
that so much
thank you again i got chills through my
whole body i could see
them as these pagodas as you were
describing them in my mind it was
you know when we listen to stories each
other's stories we're giving gifts
that's how i see
stories we're really gifting each other
um with these
pleasant experiences because our brain
doesn't really know the difference
between living it
you know like being there again and and
being here now
the only difference is our our motor
cortex which is activated when we're
actually physically
moving but our brain you know going back
to the past
and really reliving some of these
moments is so good
i kind of it the researcher who i i love
and have done these workshops with she
talks about it like a multivitamin
you know the benefits you're giving
yourself by recalling the past and
sharing stories and listening to stories
is medicinal
in so many ways so yeah i encourage you
all to really
go there often and every time we go
there we're reinforcing it so it's
easier to drop in
right you know if you before bed if
you're having a hard time falling asleep
you know go to the pagodas go to your
child
you know looking into their eyes go to
the coliseum wherever it is but but
touch into it
because it's this pool of of um
nourishment and it really
you know changes you can i think
hopefully you all feel a
shift right their nervous system has
settled down and
um you know if i was just listening to
these stories after a busy day and
didn't ground myself
i wouldn't have gotten all these
wonderful sensations of tingling and
warmth and the visions of your stories
so we need that rest we need that
that stillness and rejuvenation to then
access each other
more intimately and have empathy this
deep deep embodied empathy
so that's what i would love you to take
away the time has flown by
um but that you know to take away
looking for the good it's a practice
right looking around
and even just the space you're in right
now and
appreciating um i have photos of my
family up here
and all these wonderful memories but
just looking for the good
and finding extraordinariness in the
ordinary
um especially in your students and maybe
even try looking at them
as you know through the eyes of of a
parent
you know or that that feeling of
unconditional positive regard
even especially i should say the most
difficult students who
challenge us in so many ways but yeah
also teach us some some really beautiful
lessons
so it has just been such a pleasure to
be with you
i really hope that you feel refreshed
rejuvenated that the
the tank is a little bit more full and
we can just close our eyes for
one last moment and just connect
there are how many people in this call
over 400
600 650 people that we can't see
we heard some voices but we know they're
there
all of us educators teaching
learning from our students giving of
ourselves
we're part of this community even though
we can't see each other we're here
so just taking a moment to send
these kind wishes to our whole community
you can think of these
beams of light going out from our home
all the way around the world
and at least the country right but we
can include the world
community of teachers
may we all find joy
may we all have as many moments of awe
as possible in our lives
may we all know we're not alone
may we all feel connected and safe
and healthy
and you've sent that out and now just
take a few breaths receiving
from these 650 people that have sent it
to you
just breathing in
all the good that's been sent your way
and letting it land in your body
your mind your heart
letting this feeling of connection and
ease linger
and just taking it in to the rest of
your evening
maybe the next person you make eye
contact with
just sending them kindness through your
eyes
and can open our eyes and for all the
time keepers it's exactly five o'clock
so i want to honor and respect your time
[Music]
and just say thank you so much to
our whole team to jeremy and alice and
lino for putting this all together
and all of you for coming it's been a
pleasure
and i hope we can do this again soon
really genuinely
thank you so much sam i just wanted to
end on this note from michelle which i
thought was so perfect
michelle says thank you for this brief
respite from the rigors of the day to
day
we all know that teaching has those
rigors it was a precious gift
may you also find joy and time that you
can share with others in this wonderful
practice
so thank you all for joining today thank
you sam for sharing your gifts with us
and we wish you all a wonderful spring
thank you
bye everybody